أي حرب لها خلفية ثقافية
وكان هذا بالتأكيد صراعًا بين
ثقافتين مختلفتين.لقد
طغى الفن الأوكراني لفترة
طويلة جدًا من قبل الروس
على المجال الثقافي يجب أن يكون
ساحة معركة أيضًا وعلينا القتال
في أعقاب غزو روسيا
أوكرانيا فريق صغير بقيادة ثلاثة
منسقين أوكرانيين وفنان واحد حاربوا
لتقديم أعمالهم في واحد من
أرقى المعارض الفنية في العالم ،
بينالي البندقية ،
تعلم جيدًا متى يقترب ابنك
منك في الساعة الخامسة
صباحًا  والقول يا أبي لقد
بدأوا ،
فأنت تعلم بالتأكيد أنك لا
تفكر في مشاريعهم في البندقية ، لقد كان
قرارًا جادًا للغاية لأنني
في ذلك الوقت أدركت أنه سيكون من
المهم حقًا أن يتم
تمثيل أوكرانيا على الساحة الثقافية
يمكن أن يكون لديك مشاكل مع السياسة
يمكن أن تواجه مشاكل مع الاقتصاد
حتى مشاكل عميقة وضخمة ولكن
لا يزال بإمكانك البقاء على قيد الحياة ولكن
إذا لم يكن لديك ثقافة ،  لا
توجد دولة لا توجد دولة
حيث تعرضت أوكرانيا لأزمة ، وكان على
الفريق الذي يقف وراء الجناح الفني
إعطاء الأولوية للسلامة الشخصية بالإضافة إلى
مهمتهم في نهاية المطاف ، حيث كانوا يخططون
للطرق إلى البندقية التي يقودون معظمها عبر
أوروبا مع عائلاتهم
وممتلكاتهم وأجزاء من  العمل الفني
ينبوع الإرهاق
في اليوم الأول من الحرب ، هل
تحولت قليلاً ،
لم يكن لدي أي شخص لأهتم به
بخلاف نفسي ، ربما كان
مشروعنا
اللازم للتوجه إلى الطرق الغربية محشورًا
وخطيرًا للغاية للقيادة في الوقت الذي
استغرقني  حوالي ستة أيام للوصول إلى
الحدود مع رومانيا في
غضون ذلك ، قضى بافلو ستة أيام في
ملجأ من القنابل في وسط المدينة
تم إجلاؤه من خاركيف إلى فيينا مع
زوجته وصديق ووالدتها ووالدته
البالغة من العمر 92 عامًا
وكنت مفاجأة تمامًا كما تعلم  قلت لأمي تعلم أنني
أبلغ من العمر 63 عامًا ، فأنت تعلم أنني أكبر رجل في العائلة ، لذا فأنت تعلم أنه مثل طفل ، دعنا نذهب ونذهب إلى السيارة من فضلك وعلينا مغادرة ليزا فيت  فريد من كييف تل أبيب ،
كانت حاملاً بشدة ،
لم نكن نريد التحرك
رغم أنه كان مخيفًا جدًا ، كما تعلمون ،
سمعنا انفجارات وطلقات نارية
كل
يوم تقريبًا ، استغرقت الرحلة منا ثلاثة أيام ،
تلقينا الكثير من الدعم
لاستضافتنا لمساعدتنا
هرب بوريس أيضًا للعيش ووصل أخيرًا
إلى البندقية قبل أيام قليلة فقط من
الإطلاق ،
كل رجل في أوكرانيا سيذهب إلى
ساحة المعركة ولكن لدينا العديد من الأدوار في
هذه الحرب ، لقد تلقيت رسالة من
وزارة الثقافة لتمثيل أوكرانيا
بالنسبة لي ، ليس من السهل أن أكون كذلك  هنا
لكنني سأعود
في غضون ثلاثة أسابيع
إلى أوكرانيا
في ميلانو ماريا ووجد بافلو شركة
لإعادة بناء جزء من التثبيت
الذي تركه
فريق التصميم الأصلي في كييف
ثم وصلنا أخيرًا إلى
وجهتنا في
البندقية.  معًا ، نعم
، من الجيد أن نكون معًا
هو أحد الفنانين الأكثر
إثارة للاهتمام والأكثر أهمية من
Harkiff إذا كان ينتمي إلى النوع الأول
من الجيل الأوكراني المستقل بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي
تم إنشاء
هذا العمل الفني في السياق المحلي
لمدينة هاركيف
في منتصف التسعينيات بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي ،
وبدأت طاحنته في
تدهور فكرة استنفاد
المدينة الكبيرة التي استنزفت نفسها على
عدة مستويات.  من الواضح بالنسبة لبابلو
أن المفهوم ألهم أكثر من عشرة
أعمال فنية ولكن لم يعمل أي منها مع
تدفق المياه
عندما اقتربنا منه وسألناه عما إذا
كان يرغب في
إنتاجه أخيرًا في البندقية بالنسبة له ،
كانت بداية قصة جديدة تمامًا
بالنسبة لنا للفريق بأكمله  بالنسبة للفنان
، كان من المهم للغاية
إنتاجه بالطريقة التي كان عليها دون أي تغييرات طفيفة
دون أي ضرر دون أي
تعديلات تعرفها فقط لإظهار أن
العمل الفني موجود بغض النظر عن
مدى الاهتمام الجديد الذي نحصل عليه
الآن ، فأنت تعلم أنه
مؤلم قليلاً لأننا نفهم أن
هذا الاهتمام يتم دفعه بالدم
والضحايا في بلدنا كما تعلمون
روسيا تقول الآن أوكرانيا ليست
دولة  ليس لديها
ثقافة لا وجود لها ، تعلم أن
الثقافة هي سؤال يتعلق بالأمن القومي ،
الثقافة هي كيف يمكننا أن نعيش معًا كيف يمكن
لكل هؤلاء الأفراد المختلفين أن يجدوا
قواعد للعمل
كمجتمع لا أشعر بنفسي حتى كفنان
هنا أشعر أكثر من ذلك بكثير  أنا كمواطن
من واجبه أن يمثل
بلده وهذا كل شيء وكذلك جميع
القيمين على المعرض لدينا نفس
الفكرة بالطبع إنها ليست رمزًا متفائلًا
ولكن في النهاية وجودها
في هذا في البندقية أعتقد أنه سيكون كذلك.  إعطاء
الأمل لإظهار أن أوكرانيا قادرة على
القيام بأشياء ليس فقط الاختباء في
الملجأ وليس فقط البقاء على قيد الحياة ولكن فعل
أشياء لبناء المستقبل